bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7,8
week-end votre magazine dédié aux
sorties et vos loisirs
au sommaire de ce numéro l'art floral
s'expose à versailles jusqu'à dimanche
les adhérents de la société horticole
des yvelines font découvrir leur passion
à travers une cinquantaine de
composition 23 danseurs et comédiens sur
l'espace racines de saint rémy les
chevreuse entraîne le public dans un
voyage sur les origines de la vie et à
coignières c'est un vaudeville qui se
jouera dans un fil à la patte de georges
feydeau
vous découvrirez les folles aventures de
ferme en bois d'enghien avant son
mariage
mais tout d'abord nous débutons ce
magazine avec notre première invité
bernard philippe résidents d'animaux
europe une association de huy en
courtoise bonjour bonjour et vous
proposer ce samedi de découvrir ou de
redécouvrir la commune de guyancourt
avec un rallye vélo
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un rallye vélo
l'idée est venue avec la maison de
quartier mono dans un premier temps avec
qui nous sommes en lien depuis
maintenant des années sur des activités
diverses et variées notamment des
animations et l'idée étant sur une
journée de faire découvrir guyancourt de
façon un peu différente
et petit à petit au fil de la
conversation il est des idées qui sont
venus nous avons décidé donc de prendre
en compte l'ensemble du territoire de
l'ue en cours uniquement le cadre du oui
en cours et d'intégrer les différentes
maisons de quartier comme relais de ce
rallye vélo ça va faire découvrir la
ville à travers quoi ces acteurs sont
architecturés 2g 3g faire découvrir la
ville au travers bas de ces pistes
cyclabes de deux lieux qu'on ne connaît
pas forcément même si on doit encore toi
depuis longtemps en ce qui concerne
le vélo voilà donc c'est essentiellement
les pistes cyclables il ya très peu de
traversée de rands route et ont sécurisé
chaque fois contraire cinq grandes
routes et en ce qui concerne la maison
de quartier ça permet aux habitants qui
participeront à ce rallye de découvrir
pour certains certainement les activités
qu'il ya dans leur maison de quartier ou
celle du quartier d'à côté voilà et vont
aller de lieux en lieux avec des énigmes
des épreuves
voilà tout à fait donc vous partir
chaque équipe partira de la maison de
quartier dans laquelle il s'est inscrit
donc il ya selon elle 1,2 quartier
plusieurs équipes et passera de maison
de quartier maison de quartier et avec
effectivement des épreuves qui
permettent de découvrir par où passait
ensuite quand il arrive à la maison de
quartier est la suivante ils rendent
leur première enveloppe remplie il ya
une petite animation à ce moment là qui
est une collation d'ailleurs aussi pour
certains et ensuite ils prennent leur
enveloppe de l'étape suivante et ainsi
de suite jusqu'à la dernière maison de
quartier aux maisons de quartier on
rajoute la ville à jean monnet parce que
l'association à numéro est régulièrement
sur le village aux monnaies et donc on a
nos adhérents au nous qui partiront de
l'âme et de la ville à jean monnet ça
s'adresse à qui seulement au bilan pour
toi aux adultes aux parents et aux
enfants aux familles ça s'adresse
seulement work golliot courtois oui et
aux familles alors en prenant en compte
le fait que pour les plus petits enfin
faire 12 km il ya un endroit un peu
délicat où on passera à pied et le vélo
à la main donc ya pas de danger mais
quand même 12 km vous pouvez aller faire
donc c'est aux familles de voir pour les
plus jeunes de leurs enfants s'ils sont
capacité de le faire en tout cas avec
les les vélos avec des petits trous
derrière non ça passera pas à vélo donc
faut avoir son propre matériel ce n'est
pas l'association qui le font voilà
c'est ça les façons preuves matérielles
et dans ce cadre là on a proposé cette
semaine au travers d'un 2
si l'entreprise qui rappelle vélo
discount de venir faire réparer les
vélos
enfin dans un premier temps faire
réviser le vélo et le réparer si besoin
la révision est gratuite et cyrus une
pièce évidemment la pièce est payante
ça c'est dans le cadre de vélo discount
qui est une entreprise privée
et sinon il ya une association qui
s'appelle la bicyclette qui sera
également présenté qui a qui travaillent
autour du vélo donc aussi de la révision
de ces animaux europe la piloter tout ce
projet pourquoi vous êtes très investi
dans ce genre d'activités à numéros a
plus de 20 ans d'existence à numéros
paix n'est sur le quartier de l'europe
au moment où le quartier de l'europe
sortait de terre ont aujourd'hui car si
l'europe est largement finit donc il ya
eu plusieurs périodes de l'association
aujourd'hui on est sur comment garder
l'objet initial c'est-à-dire faire avec
les gens créer du lien prendre en compte
les personnes mais en même temps on est
obligés d'intégrer le fait que les gens
maintenant bas sont et fois pas d
historique il ya eu du tour 9 heures et
c'est donc on passe par des activités
dans l'année toute l'année autour du
théâtre enfants adultes ados autour de
visites conférences à paris en ile de
france autour de la musculation autour
de l'art plastique pour l'épauler petit
voilà et quelques animations dont voilà
le rallye vélo qui est l'aboutissement
d'un partenariat notamment comme je
disais au début avec la maison de
quartier mono avec laquelle on est sur
un comité d'animation avec d'autres
associations et on travaille sur des
animations toute l'année celle là en est
une mais elle est effectivement pour
nous anime europe
un moment fort dans notre année
voilà merci venu nous parler de ce
rallye il reste encore quelques places
mais il y en a plus beaucoup
et attention les inscriptions sont
obligatoires faut absolument se
rapprocher de vos maisons de quartier là
on change complètement sujet on part
dans de la poterie jong vais les potiers
à port royal des champs
les artistes en résidence et anima
chaque semaine des ateliers de modelage
pour partager sa passion
sephora namani et camille lambert sont
allés à sa rencontre
regardez le travail ça va être de
retrouver des lignes en fait c'est une
oeuvre qui est belle parce qu'elle tient
en fait avait avec très peu de lignes
voilà on a on a cette ligne là on a
cette ligne là on en a eu ni si elles se
rejoignent là et voilà c'est simple
c'est en même temps très efficace est
très bonne directeur d'une compagnie de
théâtre pendant dix ans jan gehl a
décidé de changer de vie après un an de
formation quotidienne aux ateliers
chemin de terre de montreuil jean guével
s'est installé en résidence aux granges
du domaine national de port royal des
champs
il est pratique la sculpture le modelage
et le tour une véritable passion pour la
terre
c'est la matière c'est le travail de la
terre il ya vraiment d'aider des
sensations fortes à la fois dans le tour
et dans le
dans le travail avec les mains en fait
je crois énormément aux gestes je trouve
ça enrichissant valorisant et puis ici
en plus c'est le calme en fait il ya
vraiment un bras une vraie adéquation
entre la nature et puisqu'on peut ce
qu'on peut proposer comme projet coin
jean guével fait découvrir sa passion en
animant des journées de tournage tous
les premiers dimanches du mois des
journées thématiques autour de la
fabrication des mots et dans gobe mais
son activité principale reste les
ateliers de modelage la plasticité de la
terre en fête une matière simple à
utiliser presque instinctive
c'est du modelage quand je parle des
deux sculptures c'est pas de la matière
qu'on enlève c'est de la matière qu'on
va ajouter donc on est dans quelque
chose qui est toujours en mouvement
sauf quand on a réussi à saisir la bonne
expression la bonne forme est là il faut
arrêter faut arriver à repérer ce moment
est arrêté à ce moment là parce que ça
tient vraiment à rien de un petit peu
plus de pattes un peu moins une pression
du doigt et on peut briser une ligne
l'activité est ouverte à tous l'atelier
met à disposition la terre faïence ou
gré le matériel et les émaux ou engobes
pour réaliser les projets personnalisés
les pièces sont cuites sur place seule
exigence pour la pratique un peu de
patience et de concentration
le prochain atelier a lieu ce samedi 28
mai de 14h à 18h pour plus
d'informations ou vous inscrire le
numéro s'affiche en bas de l'écran
pour ses 50 ans la société horticole des
yvelines propose une exposition autour
de l'art floral
une cinquantaine de composition est à
découvrir à l'espace richaud de
versailles jusqu'à ce dimanche 29 mai
pour en parler nous a rejoint plateau
céline froid ça bonjour bonjour vous
êtes co présidente de la section art
floral
oui déjà qu'est ce que l'art floral
alors l'art floral caylar d'arranger les
végétaux aussi bien frais secs que l'on
trouve dans son jardin en forêt ou alors
qu'on va acheter sur le marché voilà il
ya des codes à respecter cette ne
dissipe lina part oui c'est un petit peu
près si on peut dire il faut par rapport
au lieu à l'espace
il faut quand même respecter une échelle
pas faire du hors sujet est certaine
nous fleurs ou plantes ne se marient pas
entre al peut-être alors bon c'est vrai
qu'il faut essayer de respecter une
harmonie entre l'exotique le champêtre
c'est vrai qu'il faut essayer de rester
dans la même veine même catégorie de
végétaux donc ça s'apprend oui ça pas du
tout celle là lors de cette exposition
il ya une cinquantaine qu'on peut vous
faire découvrir le disais tout à l'heure
un avant goût de ses compositions qu'est
ce qu'on va pouvoir y voir alors
beaucoup de couleurs tous styles du
classique du moderne vraiment pour tous
les goûts
il y aura même
des allusions à la gourmandise avec des
gâteaux faits avec des fleurs ça va être
vraiment très variés pour pour tous
des fleurs des plantes fraîches oui tout
sera entièrement tout est frais voilà et
donc on croise les doigts pour 7e jusque
dimanche pour que vraiment tout le monde
en profite et fasse des belles photos et
justement face entretien comment parce
que vous les garder jusqu'à dimanche
elles ont commencé à être installées
hier trois ou quatre jours oui satin
commandes d'écrans et bien chaque matin
avant l'ouverture ont pulvérisé avec de
l'eau et ont fait un réassortiment si
vraiment les forces sont fanées on a une
réserve mais vraiment faut que ça soit
impeccable
vous parlez de classiques de
contemporain est ce qu'il ya un thème
qui est regroupe un peu toutes les
compositions de création et bien ses
éclats de fleurs c'était par rapport à
notre anniversaire
donc voilà la fête l'anniversaire voilà
l'affronter zee les créateurs sont des
professionnels ou ce sont des amateurs
avertis voire très avertis alors il ya
des professeurs de l'école mais épuisés
aussi des élèves
voilà tout le monde est dans la même le
groupe cette exposition c'est aussi
peut-être le moyen de faire découvrir
l'art floral mais depuis redonner aussi
envie aux gens oui devenir aussi bien
débutants que confirmés vraiment on peut
s'exprimer
voilà il ya aucun problème aucun
problème et en cette occasion de la fête
des mères aussi ça peut être une idée de
donner des idées
alors soit voilà voilà de venir offrir
des cours d'art floral pour l'année
prochaine par exemple des enfants delà
des cours d'art floral parce que la
société horticole à 50 ans cette année
oui donc ça fait 50 ans qu'on qu'on
propose des cours d'art floral donc
classique contemporain et donc on donne
nos cours au potager du roi de septembre
à juin et donc n'hésitez pas à venir
nous rejoindre et en 50 ans a évolué
d'une mamie n'allez peut-être les
mentalités les façons de faire aussi de
traiter la fleur donné alors au début
c'était on va dire des bouquets assez
classique que bouquet d'époque comme on
voit sur les tableaux et puis après on a
un peu évolué on a épuré pour vraiment
garder des lignes très forte et des
couleurs franches
voilà aujourd'hui 50 ans 200 adhérents
ou yvon adhérentes
oui on a vraiment principalement des
filles c'est une belle que guérini belle
association de belles sociétés
donc ça fonctionne bien oui et si vous
voulez découvrir toutes ces belles
compositions l'exposition éclats de
fleurs et donc à découvrir jusqu'au
dimanche 29 mai à l'espace richaud à
versailles
l'entrée est libre on le précise merci
celle une fois s'armer face de lui nous
la présenter
et pour ce nouveau rendez-vous
littérature le coup de coeur de la
librairie du pavé du canal à montigny le
bretonneux est allé à lagon noir d'un
hâle du ried rida sonne un écrivain de
romans noirs island et stéphanie férial
nous le présente
écoutez pauline je te présente le
dernier la mère romande indridason
maître du polar islandais
cerise sur le gâteau c'est erlendur
khemed enquête vraiment pour notre plus
grand plaisir
donc on est en 1979 en pleine guerre
froide
un cadavre vient d'être découvert dans
un labo c'est un c'était un ouvrier qui
travaillait sur la base militaire
américaine à côté d'un aéroport
effectivement 79 on est en pleine guerre
froide les américains avec plusieurs
bases militaires et notamment en islande
ce qui plaisait pas toujours à la
population évidemment et qui ressort
beaucoup justement dans le roman parce
que l'anc est forcément doit être menée
sur cette base sauf que les américains
freine des quatre fers pour d'événements
pas pas qu'on rentre dans la base donc
c'est toujours tout aussi passionnant
c'est plutôt sombre c'est plutôt du
roman entre roman noir et polar comme
toujours chez indridason ski et moi je
trouve qu'il fait vraiment la pâte
supplémentaire c'est que justement il y
a un relent d'or qui sont son héros
fétiche
là en plus avec la littérature ont peur
qu'on peut remonter dans le temps donc
il a si les tout jeunes enquêteurs il a
30 ans mais il a toujours cette
obsession et c'est ses démons intérieurs
qui fait qu'ils mènent les enquêtes un
peu parallèle qui n'ont rien du tout
avec à voir avec cette histoire sans
trame et qui nous fait découvrir aussi à
un d'islande et de son héros vraiment
extrêmement attachant
au commencement il n'y avait rien rien
que le néant un vide infini
comment miniscule lettre que nous sommes
avant vous avoue nous pu partant de vase
a croisé le chemin de la vie avec les
chroniques du ciel et de la terre la
compagnie les comptes de la vallée vous
embarque dans une réflexion sur la vie
et emilia son putsch est venu pour nous
en parler
bonjour monsieur vous êtes la directrice
artistique de la compagnie
pourquoi ce spectacle pourquoi pas
c'est un spectacle que j'ai voulu écrire
voilà qui m'est venue un jour où je me
suis dit si demain tout s'arrête
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait deux je suis
venu et jusqu'où je serais arrivé c'est
vraiment ce qui vous inspire et qui vous
a fait raconté des origines à beurre
c'est vraiment plus loin quelque chose
due qu'est ce qui est autour de nous qu
est-ce qui qu'est ce qui fait qu'on est
ce qu on est qu est ce qui fait qu on
fait ce qu'on fait et voilà deux dans
tout ce monde qui va très vite et qui
surconsomment qui va se remettre un
petit peu à notre place et à notre petit
est qu'est ce que nous sommes nous
petits petits êtres humains sur cette
terre et dans cet univers pour ce
spectacle vous avez décidé de mêler deux
genres la danse et le théâtre
mais comment ça s'est passé de façon
générale au compte de la vallée les
spectacles contes sont toujours
pluridisciplinaire donc on et voilà de
vraiment dans le mélange des disciplines
et j'avais très envie de monter un
ballet qui donnait envie et donc donc ça
s'est fait naturellement voilà du
comment communiquer aussi au delà des
mots par le corps et le visuel n'est une
discipline qui est plus prépondérante
que l'autre la plus de danse ou pièce de
théâtre le coût de plus de danse c'est
un ballet à la balade théâtrale donc
c'est donc c'est plutôt le texte qui
vient ponctuer des tableaux alors avant
d'en parler un peu plus je vous propose
de regarder un extrait comme ça en se
forgeant nôtre
il ya quand même un certain sentiment de
poésie me par le choix de la musique
c'était une volonté aussi oui en théorie
inciter les gens à rêver
le rêve est la base de toutes les
grandes choses arriver à voyager à se
faire leur propre réflexion
ouais c'est vraiment un spectacle
contemplatif où d'un seul coup on rentre
dans une autre dimension et on peut
prendre ce qu'on veut un peu à droite à
gauche et regarder observer et ensuite
chacun peut se faire son histoire ça
s'adapte ça sente à tous à tous les âges
les enfants les adultes ou c'est quand
même un peu mais qu'un pc grand public
c'est grand public ça peut faire un peu
peur aux tout petits c'est être un peu
inquiétante mais mais quoi qu'il en soit
c'est très visuel et ça fait rêver
même les plus jeunes sur sa l'on
retrouve 23 danseurs et comédiens
oui ce sont des professionnels où il ya
des amateurs eh bien il ya les deux
voilà parce qu'elle compte de la vallée
on prend sur audition et on aime
justement mais les professionnels
amateurs éclairés
donkey qui vont qui vont avoir quand
même une une volonté de s'investir dans
quelque chose pour donner un spectacle
de qualité et le but c'est que chacun
puisse apprendre apporter sa pierre à
l'édifice pour monter un beau projet en
comédien comme des amateurs ou se pose
qu'ils ont eue professionnelle à côté ça
doit pas être facile de se préparer
vous en êtes à votre deuxième année vous
êtes bien rodé maintenant sur ce
spectacle on essaye on essaye d'être
d'être au top
voilà une partie de l'équipe qui a
changé donc il a fallu reprendre pas mal
de choses à zéro et et puis voilà on a
voulu justement reprendre cette année
encore ce spectacle là pour l'améliorer
l'emmener plus loin et fait rêver encore
plus de monde
merci à myla santucci pour rêver avec
les chroniques du ciel et de la terre
c'est donc dimanche 29 mai à 19h à
l'espace jean racine de saint rémy les
chevreuse il reste des places
laissez vous tenter on a parlé dans ses
théâtres on va plutôt se concentrer sur
le théâtre avec notre dernière l'invité
christophe leray bonjour bonjour vous
faites partie de la troupe du crâne ou
vous présenter un nouveau spectacle
alors là on est on passe de la poésie et
du rêve a dû
lui du vaudeville georges feydeau peux
me présenter la pièce est bien cette
pièce c'est avant tout l'histoire d'un
homme qui s'appelle faire mon bois
d'enghien qui est dans de sales draps
fernand bois d'enghien est pris au piège
parce qu'il se marie il doit se
débarrasser mais sans succès de sa
maîtresse lucette gautier qui devient
encombrante seulement 7 cette femme qui
est un peu loufoque et une femme fatale
aussi qui est chanteuse de café-concert
et bien a été embauché pour la future
belle mère du futur marié donc le jour
du mariage et bien fernand se retrouve
en présence de sa maîtresse et de sa
femme et donc tout explose c'est un
véritable feu d'artifice et c'est là que
le quiproquo arrive on n'a pas donné le
titre de la pièce c'est un fil à la
patte de georges feydeau peut-être des
plus célèbre de georges fait donc
pourquoi avoir fait ce choix parce que
c'est quelque chose qui a été jouée
partout tout à fait alors c'est vrai que
le fil à la patte c'est une pièce qui à
122 ans
mais je pense que aujourd'hui cette
pièce elle peut toujours être
d'actualité on ne peut toujours avoir un
regard intéressant sur l'oeuvre de
feydeau la force des auteurs qui
aujourd'hui sont passés à la postérité
c'est d'avoir un regard sur la condition
humaine et georges feydeau lui n'y va
pas avec le dos de la cuillère il a un
regard plutôt assez lucide justement sur
l'hypocrisie les masques tombent avec
lui et il y prend un malin plaisir
justement à dépeindre toute cette
société et je trouve que justement ce
thème est plutôt intemporel et peut
également feydeau de par son écriture à
une maîtrise des rouages comique qui
fait que c'est un vrai un vrai bonheur
et le mouvement étant lié au mot le
vaudeville en tout cas le genre du
vaudeville est un genre plutôt exigeant
et et on a eu plaisir à s'atteler à cet
univers du vaudeville beaucoup de rythme
souvent ça va crescendo faut faire
remonter le public en pression
exactement c'est facile à jouer alors je
demande l'exigence elle vient de là le
rythme demande unis
j une concentration très importante pour
les pour les comédiens mais aussi en
amont c'est un travail gigantesque
pour le metteur en scène qui est au
service de deux justement d'un auteur et
il faut rentrer dans cet univers et je
crois que monique fandi dion qui est la
fondatrice et de la troupe est également
le metteur en scène de ce spectacle a
essayé de nous transmettre toute son
énergie toute sa passion et ça a été un
an et demi de travail
c'est un spectacle tout récent vous êtes
bien ça y est c'est bien oui alors on a
mis on a commencé à travailler sur ce
spectacle à partir du début du mois
d'octobre de l'année 2015 on a mis un an
et demi on a commencé à jouer à partir
du mois de janvier 2016 donc le
spectacle a déjà eu plusieurs
représentations il a il est parti sur sa
lancée donc dans la troupe on combine
toujours la présentation d'anciennes
création et la production de deux
nouveaux spectacles est là donc c'est un
grand spectacle qui revient et pour
notre plus grand plaisir
on disait c'est une pièce qui est très
ancienne elle date de 1894
ça signifie costumes d'époque c'est ça
marche c'est ce qui importe c'est dans
le vaudeville exactement et puis c'est
un plaisir aussi de 2
de jouer le jeu aussi de se replonger
dans une époque alors là on est dans la
belle époque donc on est à la fin du 19e
siècle
donc on a un foisonnement de couleurs
des chapeaux haut de forme les plumes en
force et c'est toujours visuellement
très intéressant bien que dans la troupe
on soit plutôt assez on est assez sobre
en fait en général en termes de décor
mais là on s'est dit bon ben joue au jeu
et et partons dans l'univers de georges
feydeau
et justement pour pour conclure l'équipe
a pu la troupe a pu mettre un peu de sa
patte ou finalement georges feydeau
s'adapte tel quel alors j'ai envie de
dire qu'on n'a pas besoin de réinventer
feydeau il se suffit à lui-même
maintenant j'espère et ça c'est le
public qui est qui en est le seul juge
j'espère qu'on y apporte une vraie
fraîcheur une énergie il ya des
personnages hauts en couleurs c'est
vraiment une galerie et ça aussi c'est
une force chez feydeau vous avez un
général qui est complètement fantasque
un compositeur de musique ratée va la
fin c'est toute une galerie de
personnages je crois qu'ils emportent
l'adhésion et et on essaye de porter ça
avec ferveur et et on a et on essaie et
c'est ce que le metteur en scène nous
dit d'avoir l'indécence d'être et je
crois que voilà on a beaucoup de plaisir
et j'espère qu'il sera partagé ce mardi
merci christophe leray pour découvrir
cette folie ce vaudeville les aventures
de fernand de bois d'enghien se joue à
l'espace alphonse daudet de coignières
la troupe du crâne vous attend mardi 31
mai à 20h45 ont conclu cette page
spectacle avec une représentation la
merise de trappes l'association galapiat
cirque présente parasite un poème
musical et circadien qui mêle mât
chinois jeu théâtral et musique on
regarde un extrait
des hommes cherchent
certains ont des yeux d'or
zap et ils suivent en famille zioui leur
respiration d'être des hommes au
crépuscule mais bon
il termine son set week-end avec deux
derniers rendez vous attrape
l'association trappe action solidaire
propose un tournoi de football dimanche
29 mai de 10 heures à 19 heures les
fonds recueillis ce jour-là permettront
à l'association d'amener des familles en
vacances à la mer au mois de juillet
villepreux images fixes elle organise
deux jours de festival autour de la
photo panoramique des expositions des
ateliers et des conférences sont à
propos sont proposés aux amateurs et
curieux
le programme est à retrouver sur le site
internet et avant de nous quitter un
dernier rendez-vous le parc de la coudre
de montigny le bretonneux l'accueil tout
le week-end les championnats
départementaux d'athlétisme
ça commence samedi 28 mai à 13h45
environ 600 athlètes sont attendus voilà
le 7-8 week-end est terminée je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis la semaine
prochaine c'est sephora la manic vous
retrouver